welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled tips for successful
single cell and single nucleus rna
seek it's my pleasure to introduce you
to luciano martillato
scientific director single cell core
laboratory
harvard medical school for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them to the q a box
our speaker will address your the
questions following at the end of the
presentation
please join me in welcoming luciano
martillato
i will now join i will now turn the
presentation over to him
hello everyone again so so at this part
of the talk i'm gonna
continue with the the next set of slides
as i mentioned in the previous
at the end of the previous presentation
so i'm gonna discuss a little bit of uh
the the some of the hurdles that we need
to address when we
considering single cell experiments but
also i'm gonna finish with that i'm
gonna continue now with a few
slides related to what are the
technology options so this
already you have if you've been in the
previous person in the previous session
you've seen probably this slide in which
you know i wanted to
sort of enumerate the three potential
ways that we have at the moment to do
a single cell around ac causing a
nuclear aeronautic
and one is on there is in in wells the
others is nanowires for microwaves and
the other is a microfluidics and i'm
going to
go in a little bit of details in in some
of those
so the the one technology that is uh
is also is in wells and is the one one
of my favorites
is it's known as smart sick or switching
mechanism
at the five prime end of the rna
templates
this is usually a weller base plate
technology
and the way that you start is you
prepare your sample
you process your sample you prepare your
single cell isolates and then you sort
your cells into wells and would you i
have your unique barcode
identified of an individual cell so one
key clever part of this technology and
that's that's what you know kind of
boosts this technology to
to be widely used is this
uh ability or this feature that
it was taken from the maluni marine
leukemia virus
reverse transit place which is it has
the ability to when it gets to the end
of the transcript it adds
a series of c's and dashes
are uh used by
the by also by the developers at the
time
to er to anneal to
and template switching oligo which is
something that we introduce
within the with the master mix and now
the ends and when it gets to that
end it it switches the template and then
uses the the the template switch oligo
as a as a template to create a dock
inside for the
ascdna amplification and after that you
just move
into the preparation of the library in
the standard ways one of the things
that makes this technology super useful
is the fact that it allows you to
profile full transcript information now
not
all the technologies available at the
moment can do full transcript uh
information this is one of the few of
not the only one that can do that
of course you from from technologies
like 10x you can get
cdna full length but we are actually
sampling
or counting the three prime or the five
prime of the transcript in this case
we are actually we have to sequence when
we prepare the libraries we have
information
uh of the entire transform they have
been serious
a series of new developments like you
know smart 6 smart scene 2
3 4 and smart sig total there's several
uh variations of the of these
technologies some of them uses
use umi some others don't but the key
aspect of this is allows you to see uh
full track
information and obviously when you do
footnote
information you get a much richer
information about the
uh not just only about counting
molecules like when we do five prime or
three prime but you also can see
a fusion genes or or
transcript yeah so translate variability
in terms of splice variants and isoforms
now the the other very cool approach
that you can use also
in is is called say well this is uses a
nano world technology
uh essentially what you do is you
prepare your sample prep in the same way
that you prepared before
and then you call load your beads which
are barcoded bits these are bits that
contain oligos that i have been
printed in those bits and this oligos
are this is a solid bead
so the these are co-loaded into
a microwave array and then you will have
one cell
one bit per well in most cases
and then you get the capture of the rna
using the oligodet as i mentioned before
and then here you just recover the bs
and you run reverse transcription
in mass and then from there you go
into the library prep and
in the standard illumina library
preparation so this
is uh hopefully will be commercialized
soon apparently it was
it was it was done that was going to be
done by honeycomb biotechnologies prior
to coving 19
mess but now has been a little bit
delayed but we hope that we can
get more accessibility and to be able to
democratize
the access to to this technology in the
near future
uh one of cool this extension of this
technology is this
is called segway s3 which is the second
strand
synthesis which is an extension in the
sense that it uses the same tech but it
actually adds
some molecular biology tricks to be able
to pick up
a transcripts that are lowly expressed
and that is based on the fact that
if you remember the template switching
reaction that i mentioned before
this is not a 100 efficient reaction is
actually not very efficient
in in some scenarios so what these guys
have been able to do
is just to trick this phenomenon
uh trick this this situation enable
using a smart sig priming which is a
random primer that binds
randomly along the the recently
synthesized rna
irrespectively if you accept
irrespectively of whether
it has been a templar switched or not
and then you are
rescuing the uh those transients that
have not
been template switched because you are
generating a second strand
using a an additional primer
so in that case then you use the smart
the smart sig little tail that you add
in that primer to amplify those
transitions
that is something something that has
improved this in the technology
significantly
and it allows the author to be able to
identify
the genes like cytokines and receptors
and
control factors that are usually lowly
expressed this is also a nice trick that
i've been using the
uh in slide sig 2 which is uh
is it's not a special tranquil atomic
technique but uh
the is called slicing originally but
this is the version 2 which has
incorporated this trick and has
increased the amount of uh transcript
that you can recover per spot
the next technology is bb wrap so this
is a macro weld base essentially what
you
use here is a it's a so you have a micro
weld chip in which you load the cells
and then the cells will load by gravity
into these
honeycomb wells here that you see in
this
slide on the left and then you add the
beads on top of this and there is a one
bit per well so essentially what you are
getting is
one bit one cell per well you can you
also have
a scanner that allows you that will you
know essentially help you with the
workflow
but it allows you to sort of count
and measure viability of the cells in
real time
to be able to determine the double rate
also in real time without having to
guess because you actually can't see the
the cells and the beats co-localizing
so one of the cool things with this bb
rav sodi is that it has a
you know the video absolutely has a
system has a series of applications
that are completely um
streamlined in in the single site
workflow so you have
the ability to do absinthe which is a is
a
it's a technology that is essentially
very similar
if not the same to side seek and then
you
get the ability to do multiplexing and
then you get the
the i mean also the ability to do target
amplification
like targeting uh rna-seq or you can do
whole
transcriptome rna-seq and you also can
do vdg recombination
which means that you can actually see a
b cell and t cell chronotypes and
and also it also contains
they also offer the ability to do that
analysis and interpretation
in their in-house software
now then we have the microfluidic which
is essentially they are more or less
the same essentially what you have is a
a bead
inlet a cell inlet and reverse
encryption inlet and an
oil inlet so all of these uh
uh inlets will feed the content into
these microfluidic
channels and then the cells will
encounter with
the beads and the oil and generate this
droplet that you can see
on the right and as you can see here you
may not see the cells but you can see
that they contain the beads and then
those the in some of these depending on
the technology
so those beads can be actually solid
beads or dissolvable beads
so here is a sort of like a a comparison
between the three technologies we have
in drop at the top so as i mentioned
before in in drop
this is a it's a it's not a dissolvable
bead it's
it's and it's a semi-solid bead but the
way that you release the oligos is
by um illuminating the same with uv
light
and there is a light
label um life label or your nucleotide
that gets released and that is what
then eventually it's going to prime the
reverse encryption there is uh depending
on the enzyme that you use
you may or may not have the template
switching but in the
standard intro the template switching is
not needed because what we are doing
is an in vitro transcription of that
cdna
and then after the cdna in vitro
transcription uh that's that's your
amplification of your cdna
of your rna in this case and then you do
after that
what you do is it's a a reversal
encryption again
and when you do the robust encryption
you use um
the random primers that will eventually
uh also introduce the docking site for
cdna amplification and after that you
generate the library
okay now in this case the rest
encryption does happen
inside the droplet we have modified this
here in the lab we have modified this
technology to actually introduce
template switching inside the droplets
and also outside the droplet ink which
increases
remarkably the amount of umis per cell
and the amount of
genes per cell that we can detect and
we actually can decide from the same
sort of emulsion whether we want to do a
standard in-drop or
switch drop which is the technology that
we are using at the moment
now then we have dropsick this is a a
much
it actually came around the same time
that in drop
he is instead using a semi-solid bead
uses a solid bead
this uh this oligosano released from the
beads the oligos are actually
covalently bound to the beads and then
they actually going to capture
the messenger rnas after the lysis of
the cell
and there is no reverse encryption
happening inside the cell what you do
is a is a droplet
breakage and then you clean up that cdna
that that rna that is bound to to the
beads
just through the polity and then after
that what you do
is that reverse transcription in the
standard way and then
you do have a templation reaction
happening
in this in this case and then you
perform the library preparation
using the standard aluminum procedures
and they and then of course we have the
most
uh known foreign by everyone which is
the
10x 10x has actually facilitated the why
that all these procedures is done
the difference between the the two
before and then x is that
to be able to do in drop and drop sig
you actually need to have an operator
that
is able to handle the complexity of the
system
whereas in 10x you just simply had a
little button that you push and
everything works beautifully almost
every time
and what you have is again here you
capture the cells and the beads and
in in droplets uh in the presence of
a lysis reagent and reverse
transcription reagents
so the lysis region actually is within
the bead so when the beads dissolve
release the
the the detergent they light the cells
the rnas
is released is captured by the oligo dt
that have also this part of the
bead oligo that is also released the
rational encryption happens
in the cell in in the droplet the
templar switching also happens in the
droplet
and after that you do a cdna
amplification step and then you
your library preparation okay now it's
the
they look slightly different but the the
ultimate goal is the same it's just to
get cells that are barcoded with a
particular
dna sequence that has that allow us to
then
uh identify the transform coming from
the different cells
so obviously the the way that this the
workflow
the complexity of the different
workshops actually affect
how long it takes to do uh to work with
one or the other
to from from the sample prep to uh
to library preparation in the case of
in-drop the standard intro is one of the
longest one
for the new version that we have is
actually very similar to
10x so it takes around seven hours as
well here but you know usually you don't
do it in seven hours you do it
in in a couple of days but you could do
it in in seven hours if you like
this is a comparison across the all the
the different platforms things that i
have been able to you know
collect over the years to just
showing you here what are the the
advantages and disadvantages of some of
those
uh i think one of the things that i want
to draw your attention to is
if they capture efficiency you will see
that some of them
have very high capture efficiency and in
case of drop c has a very low capture
efficiency
in the case of 10x is is pretty constant
is is anything between 50 and 70 percent
in the case of intro it's around the
same but
70 to 80 percent the difference between
10x and and in drops
and and some of the other technologies
in here is that
with 10x you're able you can do a
simultaneous anal
brands so essentially you can run up to
8 samples
into one chip whether it's within drop
drop sig
and the other technologies you only can
run one sample at a time
and you can still do multiplexing you
can mix samples together
and run them as one sample but
you can run multiple samples in parallel
so the other thing that i want to show
that to discuss here is the
some of the strength and weaknesses of
some of these technologies
in the case of 10x i think one of the
strengths
strength is that it's a very easy
user-friendly
uh technology you don't need to be a
super high core molecular biology to be
able to run this and i think it's
probably the most
difficult part of 10x is how they
continuously
change the reagents and things are
getting updated so you need to be
up-to-date with
with all of this but other than that
it's very simple
just loading jp in the machine and
everything works
just fine then with in-drop
it's i guess the advantage is that it's
um
[Music]
it's a very open source and a very open
system in which you can do and undo
anything you want because you have full
control of
what it what is that you're doing you
can change the reverse encryption buffer
you can change the bit size you can
change
the ratio of bits to cells you can
change the amount of volumes that you
have in your bit so you can change
everything because you control
that you you can actually you can
actually
make your own bits with it the same with
the other with some of the other
technologies with 10x is a little bit
more of a close
environment but of course this this is
not a company
obviously i have to clarify that in drop
also is
commercialized as a by one cell bio
uh you know it's a it's a it's a great
instrument it's a
they have solved the most of the
hardware but
still you need to be able to to to
operate it
and in the case of uh intro by dropsing
you need to know
how to operate the system it's not a
very simple system to
to operate in the case of
the others instrument obviously for
smashing you need to know and you have a
fax
for pd rhapsody uh you it's a it's a
very very simple system to use you have
everything set up there you even have
the pipettes to load
on on that and because of segway
i think once everything is
commercialized by honeycomb technology
hopefully soon it's going to be very
simple as well so i don't expect major
uh major problems with that now on the
final
i would say the witnesses here is as i
said for in drop is it difficult to run
the same for dropseek
for 10x is an expensive instrument okay
and it's also an expensive set of
reagents so
this is this is probably uh one of the
difficulties for for for some labs not
being able to afford an x
but uh one good thing with gen x is that
they have a
tremendous high very good support team
and they also have
a very high quality kit so there's no
much i can say
against that because you know in my
experience it's been
fantastic every single time and
with the case of rapsodies you know it's
expensive it's not as expensive as 10x
but it's still expensive and in case of
smart sig it's
it's definitely expensive and it's not
high throughput at all
okay
now uh yeah so one of the important
thing that i wanted to highlight here is
that
one we do all this processing and and
this is probably how
it's going to make more sense to people
that have been
following all these the previous
presentation as well
uh there are several cases as you go
during the steps of of
sample prep and capture and barcoding
and library prep
however the sum the quality of the
sample how good your sample prey has
been
how great your cells are
we will know how bad yourselves are we
will not know until cdna amplification
because sometimes we can see whether the
rna has been degraded or not
and in in other citation probably the
most expensive ones is
only happens at the analysis which by
then you have already sequenced your
sample
okay and sequencing is not a cheap
exercise
so with this i want to say that that's
if
for those that were in the first part of
the talk sample prep is one of the most
important things and it has to matter to
you
it's very key that you keep your samples
happy okay if you if you ruin your
samples
if actually if you get your samples
right let's let's go on a positive you
know if you get your samples or
samples right eighty percent of your
experiment
it's done then it's up to the
buying from magicians to get things
interpreted and obviously
your biology knowledge
so here are some of the success tips for
success
in in the prep in the preparation of
your sample
you need to keep your rna technique
sharp it's very common to get a little
sloppy as we do many many samples and
you know we forget to do a few things to
ironize up your pipettes and things like
that
these are very simple things to do and
it doesn't take a lot of time but people
tend to forget
you definitely i i particularly
recommend and every single person that i
consult
to do to run an experiment that is your
pilot
do not rush to the final experiment
because it's
it's prone to to be to to be doomed so
what you need to do is just run a small
pilot that is representative of your
original experiment that you plan for
for
for your biology and then only then
you do it so get to know your sample
that's that's what the pilots allow you
to do okay to see
what parts are moving what are the
moving parts and then you can adjust
them
uh try to achieve high viability if you
get 90
viability great if you get anything
above 70 it's okay too
below 70 percent you know say it's it's
up to you
i would not recommend because obviously
you are going to introduce the cells in
some samples and then
what you're going to do is just
introduce a lot of background and worse
you're also going to waste a lot of
money in
um in sequencing of cells that actually
are dead cells and potentially stress
cells
the one thing that you need to keep is
also keep your free floating or ambient
rna
as low as possible as minimal as
possible and that usually happen
when you let the cells stand for too
long in in
on ice even ice is the ice is not for us
to for the cells to be happy is for to
reduce
this the restaurant creep so the stress
is not actually
visualized in your transcriptome but it
doesn't
that's not the temperature in which a
cell is happy so
if you keep them for true long day
eventually it's going to start popping
up and releasing the rna and the rna is
gonna end up in your
in your cell suspension which it will
end up in your droplet
and then you're gonna have an average of
all the cells in every single cell
okay so that's not what you want to have
so they that's why you need to avoid the
waiting times
if you wait for too long the cell will
end up clamping because
when the cells die they will release
some dna and the dna
makes the cells to get stuck to each
other okay
so if you if you can and if your sales
is
resistant to it most of the cells are
but you know some cases they are not
use some blocking reagent you can use
bsa you can use
fbs but make sure that the technology
that you're using is compatible with
those
uh supplements that you are most of them
are but you know just check
user on this inhibitor as much as you
can it could be an expensive
reagent to have in your samples but if
you can use this is much better
and when you prepare a lot of samples
the suggestion is to stagger your
samples don't bring all the samples at
the same time because
you may not be able to run them or
because for example if you're going to
do something like
in drop or switch rob or dropsy you're
not going to be able to run many samples
at once so what you need to do is
you need to stagger the sample just
bring them one and then
by the time that the other is finishing
just bring the second one so far
in the case of 10x is more or less the
same the only
advantage with the nexus you can run
eight at the same time but sometimes
preparing examples take a long time okay
especially if you're sorting
okay and you're you're this this cell
that you are actually trying to isolate
from that
is not very abundant every sorting time
may take too long so then
you have cells floating there for a long
time
uh yep so one thing that you need to do
is try to avoid the doublets because we
want to do single-sided sequencing
you don't want to do single the uh
doublet sequencing
so what we want to do is try to remove
the
as many doubles as we can or prevent
actually normal prevent
as many doublets as we can or clamps and
in some situations you can even do
dnas because as i mentioned before one
of the causes by which the cells
get stuck to each other is because of
the dna that have been released after
cell death and uh
get the cells all clamped to each other
you may use dnas
as a step uh prior to
the cdna um prior the capture of the
cells into droplets are well
but you obviously you need to remove the
the dnas
in the media so you know you trade them
and you that you remove
and also you need to remove the breed as
much as you can the debris is sort of
like a magnet for every
single thing that is going on and if the
debris is captured within the droplet
all the well is going
if you guys if it carries some sort of
uh rna
it's going to be tran transcribed if it
is for example
poly adeline laden all right and
the removal of the dead cell is a little
bit more controversial
in my particular case i only
suggest to do that's a removal when you
are absolutely sure what is that is
dying because if you don't know what is
dying you may be biased in what you're
seeing
at the end okay or so you you may want
i have cases in which you know we were
running experiments and we were treating
the cells
we collagenase we were dissolved
dissociate the tissue
everything looks fine but when we had
the tissue
measure viability was 40 viable so we
would remove that we get 95
viability great but what you know what
was
what were the cells that died i mean
what is that i'm seeing so what i'm
if you are interested in what survive
digestion and tissue preparation yeah go
go for it but if you really want to know
the biology of that
after the cell dead removal
whatever you are measuring may have
nothing to do with the biology that you
were after
at the time of harvest so i would
suggest
think about whether you want to do this
a removal based on the biological
question that you have
now the other thing that you that i want
to mention is that the tissue
of origin here is also on the density
and the disease state and the societal
matrix
all of that is going to affect the
type of processing but also it may
affect the direction of your experiment
you may want to do single nuclei instead
of single cell aromasic
and in this case i'm going to make a
parenthesis and talk a little bit very
briefly
on single nucleonic and why i think it's
important
so single nuclear arresting has this
ability of expanding the droplet basing
of
genomics but it's not just only drop the
base but it's also
a plate based it allows you to see this
to do a toxic and also single nuclear
and and single
nuclear arrhythmic and significant toxic
from the same
cell it provides a solution from
materials that have been
frozen and archived for many years you
know
that if it has been frozen and no
cryopreserved
like snap freezing this tissue is gonna
be damaged and it's not gonna be
uh you know you won't be able to get to
recover
live cells which is one critical thing
that we need for single cell rising
so for a case of red tumors it's very
rare
for red tubes to be able to get a sample
that is fresh
you know because they are red they never
happen
or happen very often that they don't
have them very often
and they rarely happen when you're
waiting for them okay
so what and um and most of these red
teams
they are already in tissue banks so and
they have not been cryopreserved
because they were not
you know 10 years ago 12 years ago we
didn't think about oh you know we are
going to
do a great preservation because they may
we may
need this humor for single
there are a lot of surgeons and
scientists and clinician scientists that
have done that before
and and and kudos to them but there are
all the situations in which that didn't
happen so we have those tissue banks and
we want to use them
so single nucleonic allows you to to
to essentially make use of this untapped
genetic material that otherwise we will
not be able to use
for some tissues that are dissociation
resistant so
as i mentioned in my in the previous
part of the talk sometimes
you don't know uh what's the composition
of the tissue and you may be bias in
your uh your sample or single cell
suspension
composition because some part of your
tissue is not dissociating very well
okay so there may be a group of cells
that are secreting a particular type of
tracerial matrix that is not
very well digested for typical enzymes
so what you will end up doing is biasing
your single cell population because you
are not
really dissociating those
cells in the environment
microenvironment so
when those situations happen and you
suspect that
you know single nuclear analysis allows
you to lyse the tissue and release the
nuclear and
off you go and also when you have an
issue maintaining viability of the cells
for example in the case of post-mortem
tissue
these are digits that are already
decaying they are dying
and and and if you have problem
maintaining viability the best way to do
is just
just snap free it's not free the tissue
you
stop time there and then you do lysis
and the nuclear will have the expression
of the cell
at the time of you of freezing
of course seeing a nuclear arresting is
not
it's a great approach okay but
if you get the chance to do single cell
i will always choose single cell
personally because you know you have
more rna in a cell
that in the nucleus okay so less than
one percent of the rnas and then you
so obviously if you are losing 99
of the rna what you are sampling is
whatever is a bundle in the nuclei
so there you know there is another
school of thought i said well
at least we can use those samples okay
and and if there have been plenty of
studies in which the nuclear have shown
to be very similar
uh to what you get from cells and that
it's
uh you know that's that's something that
has been already shown and it's
a lot of paper of course there are other
papers that said the opposite but it
also
depends on the sample type
so this is an example of something a
little test that we run in the lab
a few years ago when we were just
working on simulcaronesic and what did
you compare
whole cells versus nuclei that is loaded
directly into the chromium
instrument or a nuclear that have been
sorted so as you can see when you when
you try to glance at this together
because of the batch effect because we
are working with different
type of samples this the whole cells and
the nuclei don't cluster together they
don't count together essentially they
just
don't intermix okay now when we look at
the
at the number of transcripts and and the
number of uh
umis counts that we get you know of
course front side you you get
many more but you you get significant
number of counts for
for nuclei all right so it's not
something that we get nothing
okay we get sufficient information but
when we look at the microcontract
content and especially in this
particular sample type which was we knew
that it was
high it's a it's a highly metabolic cell
line
we look at the amount of mitochondria
how it goes from
a huge amount okay nearly in some cases
you get
above 20 percent of microcontroller
rates coming from that
to something that isn't below one
percent
okay so and that's you know it's it's a
small improvement
in in in how much wasted rates you you
get but it's still
it's important okay and
so what i want to say with this is that
you still get sufficient information
from uh from from nuclear
and one thing that you can do if you do
you know an integrative analysis that
you know harmonization of the data you
actually
you will be able to see that even though
the the cells and the nuclei
are you know the the the core of genes
are different you actually you're able
to put these
cells to uh into one single disney plot
or you might plot in this case
and you will see that every single
cluster is populated by cells and by
nuclei which
means that you can
there is a lot there is sufficient
information in the nuclei
to be able to be able to find the same
anchors
in the cells that uh you know from what
they
theoretically come from from the same
type of cell okay
so this this has been shown also this is
a zelda but it's been also shown
in tissues and it's you know this
highlights
that in situations in which single cell
is not possible singular can be a
a very powerful approach to to
be able to use those samples
now the the other thing that i wanted to
say is that
sometimes uh some when you do the
association sometimes
some as i mentioned before some regions
of the tissue associated better than
others
okay so this is something that you need
to you need to have in mind
and especially if you know something
about the traceabilian matrix that is
decisions are composed there are some
some
strategic matters a little bit more
thermoplastic and really hard to
dissociate so you may need to consider
some other
sort of treatment for that and if you
don't want to really
bias your sample prep
the one thing is important to note is
that you know
the fact that some of these technologies
use umis
that doesn't really affect or doesn't
really correct
anything that happened before the
reverse transcription which means
when the cell was alive so if you stress
the cell
and the cell or you or the the treatment
that you do to the cells because you
dissociate and you know
and that is not going to be corrected by
the um is the um is only it's gonna be
it's gonna be correcting or it's gonna
be able to correct anything that happens
afterwards in terms of errors and pcr
errors that may happen
and you'll be able to to count what is a
real molecule from
something that is a pcr duplicate okay
but it's not going to correct
any issue that may happen with any
stress if the cell is stressed
it may likely to transcribe some genes
that like hit your protein some
some related to stress and that is going
to be in your data and that is going to
probably test your data okay but the ums
are not going to control that
so and one thing that i want you to
remember is that the rubber
transcription
so usually the dissociation happen at 37
degrees
okay the most in most scenarios so
and at 37 degrees the transcriptional
machinery
is fully active so which means that any
stress
that happened to the cell and if you
stand that
incubation time because the tissue
didn't associate very well
you know and it could go anything
between 30 and
30 minutes and two hours this digestion
okay
i have we have collaborators here that
it takes them six hours to prepare the
tissue
the single suspension that's an
exaggerated amount of hours
okay and some presentations there's
nothing you can do about it but
just know that at that temperature when
you do the association
the enzyme is still active in a four
degrees it's a little bit active
but at 37 is even more so if you remove
the nutrients because you
need to do that in the absence of
nutrients
it's you know how you can't you can't
put bsa because otherwise the
the the enzymes don't work
pretty much so and then you the cells
are being released
and when they are released they lose
anchorage anchorage is
is one of the features is one of the
hallmarks of a healthy tissue
okay lack of anchorage dependent
is a feature of cancer but it's not from
healthy tissue so if you lose that
the cell would tend to die they want to
die because they triggered all these
automatic systems like
just to be because they stay sense that
they are not happy
and they need to die and that is made up
by
opportunity because it's standard
program cell death
or you can do it or anaerobic which is
the cell death
similar to apoptosis but it's related to
the lack of
um anchorage okay so if you remove all
of that
you stretch the cell and you do it at 37
degrees
and if the cell is dying all of these
things are going to be transcribed and
you're going to see it in your in your
data
so that's why is that i recommend
you to read those papers that i
mentioned in the first part of the joke
from flanagan and denisenko and
and also from madosa which are well the
vadosa is a different paper in the case
of denisenko and
flanagan's these are two papers in which
they
uh sort of validate the use of code
called projects
uh for uh to do cold dissociation
tissues which is a dissociation that can
happen in a much shorter time
than collagenase or hyaluronidase and
also
it induces it can be done at four to six
degrees
which introduces less a sort of
background
one the other important thing is when
you do the experiments you definitely
need to count yourselves
the more accurate the better because
otherwise you may
underestimate yourselves if you
underestimate yourself what you're going
to end up doing is having more sense
that you actually thought that you
captured
and then that affect how many reads per
cells you're going to recover at the end
that's
not a bigger issue because you can
resequence but you know it's important
that you that you know all of that
and the problem is when you overestimate
yourselves and then you
think that you're sampling 10 000 cells
and then you end up having 3 000 cells
okay it happens and it happens very
often
so one thing that you need to do as i
mentioned before run the experiment make
sure that you get
very familiar with the single cell
suspension that you are able to get
single cell suspensions and live cell
suspension
the same with uh make sure that you
remove the debris this is an example of
a good
sample and this is an example of a you
know sample that is okay but still have
a lot of debris
this a good prep of nuclear and this is
a prep of
uh with clampy cells on nuclei
and here is another example in which
when you do facts
if you do facts after nuclear prep how
you can actually
improve the quality of the nuclei
shorten you will remove all the debris
and then you can
put straight that into your whatever you
can do
a plate or you can do a
micro weld or you can do a microfluidics
like an x
but the quality of the nuclear after
flux is is
is is much nicer here and much cleaner
and that's a single sound
of course some nucleus are more
sensitive to facts so you need to also
evaluate that don't just go blind and
say oh i'm going to do fact sorting
because you know
it's going to say to do that no it's
just you need to make sure that you're
not damaging your nucleus
this is an example of this is a example
of single nuclear rna-seq
on a post-facts and this is
prefax and you can see that there is a
lot of ri
there's a lot of reads that are actually
outside the droplet or outside the cells
okay
so the fractions of the cell is a metric
from this is a
cell ranger output in which you uh from
from 10xin which you can see it tells
you more or less
how many of the reads that you have
sequenced per cell is actually
in the actual cell and and not in the
background so what you can see here is
that
only 31 of the reads are in the cell
okay which is it's a it's bad because
it's telling you you're just
actually wasting a lot of your rates
here in this case
the fraction raising cell is around 80
all right so and that's that's that when
you get something like that you always
get a very good quality of the rest
obviously when you have situations like
that you get a
very low um counts and you and
and you also get a very low number of
genes it doesn't matter even when you
actually sequence
you know ten times more of or ten ammo
now in terms of facts and fights what is
the best you to use if you use
facts or max well there are there are
totally different type of
um approaches okay so in the case of
facts i would say
that it has a lot of advantages it's a
it's a very robust approach
okay you can do you can definitely get
single cell suspension
you can do live and sell that and you
can actually
use multiple parameter parameters
in this case could be multiple
fluorophore or multiple
molecules that have been used to
recognize a particular group of cells
and you can also use for dna analysis in
the case of max
egg which is a magnetic activated cell
sorting is much much
gentler than the facts the number that
you can actually process
it's a is much larger than the one from
facts because you actually
put that in it's sort of like an
involved rather than being sorted
facts also you can do a lot of a lot of
sort i don't know exactly
how whether that is a really true
a true advantage but still it's
recognized as an advantage
by the community and also it's not
limited by the abolibility availability
of disorder
not every lab has assorted nearby okay
in the case of the
facts the cones are that it uses
high pressure so that can actually
damage the cell and damage the
the the nuclei and you can also stress
the cells on the nucleus okay even
though if it happens
faster the cells can actually trans
transcribe that
signal as a as a transcript and then you
actually detect them
and and of course that also introduce
biases and makes your experiments much
much longer
now in the case of the cons for the
magnetic activated self-sorting that
obviously the number of available cell
markers are not that many
so you would not be able to do also
multiple
parameters and wise uh when you enrich
an is an enrichment it's not it's not as
precise
for facts it's also an enrichment but
it's not as precise as as
uh facts because as i said before you
the fact that you can actually do
multiple
parameters multiple more detection of
motherboard molecules with multiple
antibodies
allows you to to be more precise and and
also
you cannot use max for rare
samples because you essentially will
you'll end up losing that
it's it's a very the red means that it's
very they know a lot of those cells
now counting the cells this is another
important aspect that i want to make
sure that we all are on the same page
here
so counting the cell is one of the most
important parts of the experiment
because
again you can really make a mess if you
if you miscount so in
in the the capture rate you need to
think about
that the capture rate of of all the
platforms
sort of vary between 10 and 80 percent
whether you drop sick on
one side and and 10x and intro on the
other side
essentially when you do this you need to
consider
that you may want to have around 50 to
100 cells
with an unique transcriptome i mean it
may change with the new
computational programs and and with the
new trick of the computational analogies
may coming up soon
but this is a number sort of accepted by
a large community of
the unique structure that you need to
have to actually identify
a population cluster okay so you need to
consider that
when you because if this is a you have a
red cell you need to consider how many
cells you need to actually sample to be
able to have
your research population with that
particular number of cells so there is a
there's a nice uh website by
this strategy lab called how many cells
in which you actually input how many uh
clusters with red cells you have and
then
how many cells you want her that in that
cluster to be
you know uh to be found and
how many and and with what percentage of
uh reliability and then what you do
is you just put those numbers and it
tells you with a nine percent ninety
five percent or ninety nine percent
uh um accuracy you can detect
this if you actually this number of
cells of these red cells
if you actually uh input this number of
cells so it's actually
you know it's actually pretty good and
and it's uh
we we actually used here a lot in the
case of chromium
uh you can do super loading which means
that you can actually lower more cells
and
chrome you can actually support okay
which is around ten thousand self but
you can actually pull more one thing
that you need to consider is that
you have a doublet rate which is around
zero point eight percent per thousand
cells
and so when you do that you need to
consider that
sometimes if you put too many cells
you're going to get too many tablets
all right so all of that it's
it's all of this is connected with the
fact that the number of cells that you
need that you are going to
input had to do with the capture rate
the
cluster that you want to identify how
red that cell population is
and also what it's the uh whether you
can do super loading or not
okay in the case of the next you can do
that you can put a lot of sales
and aim for a large number of cells but
at the cost of tablets
okay and also in the case of 10x
it takes you anything between six to
eight minutes to 17 minutes in the new
kids
and in the case of in drop for example
for 10 000 cells that you capture you
can it takes you around 30 minutes so if
you want to do 40 000
it's gonna take you two hours okay so it
you need to consider all of that
when you plan your experiment obviously
the accuracy of whatever you determine
at the beginning
for the first few points depends on how
good
your count is i particularly do not
trust the sort
the sorter that is usually at 30 or 40
percent up depending on what sort it is
i recommend you to check it so there is
a that offset can be actually very
annoying
and and actually can lead you to to to
misleading information and and which
will end up
affecting you how many cells you get uh
profiling at the end
and then uh obviously the inaccuracy on
these accounts
is what i was mentioning it has all
related to that
and if you want to do negative selection
you can do
you can also do positive installation
especially for 10x some of the nano
nano beads that you can do these
positive selections they are perfectly
compatible with 10x
check because not all of them are but
some mos
some some of the milani the very tiny
ones uh
are uh are perfectly okay
with most of this platform uh but if you
do not want some of those cells just
you know use negative selection and just
try to enrich as much as you can so
you can increase the the number of your
target cells
um yeah all right
so in terms of survivability as uh you
know
what you need to optimize the
dissociation to be able to get in the
good viability make sure that you check
the availability over time don't check
it once and then you just forget
but check a couple of times but don't
waste your sample don't do it like 10
times just doing
one at the beginning of the washes and
then maybe
if you can after the shorter if you're
doing sorting or something right before
your your encapsulation
and work fast but don't rush it
experiment
always stagger your samples keep the
samples at four degrees as much as you
can because
that is when the subs are not really
happy but at least they are not
transcribing the stress signal
uh keeping the buffer that the cells are
most happy in
so generally it could be you know
up to the last moment in which you
probably need to do some changes
uh in the case of 10x for example there
are some
media that are perfectly compatible with
the
with the reverse transcription step so
you can check those in their website
otherwise contact the support with other
technologies
i i would recommend you to check it
because i don't know and
and i can tell you what for in drop
switch drop and wrap sodium
for other technologies i don't know and
it's better if you if you give it a go
and check
if you think that your viability is
going down over time just consider
whether you want to run this experiment
or not because it can be it can be
really be reflected in your in the
quality of your
of your data if you have a poor
viability
what is going to happen it's going to
have a you're going to have a high
count of my 200 reads uh
and then you're going to have a lot of
background rna which you know it's going
to pass your experiment
and it's going to be really hard to to
remove you can remove it but it's going
to be really hard to remove
okay
so and one thing that is
it can happen is that some dying cells
okay especially this is something that
has been observed and demonstrated in
the denisenko paper that i mentioned
before
from the uh sort of and samuel la
parisio
some cells that passed the qc
actually can be regarded as a
transcriptionally healthy
but that doesn't mean that the cells is
healthy and those are these are
these are dying cells okay cells that i
have already
decided to die okay and and
now the decision to die it's
because they suffer some stress and they
express for example
annexing five and that's what you detect
as a dead cell
so what the paper also tells you is that
not necessarily what you see
as an external marker like a an x five
reflects the healthiness in the
transcriptome
so you may need to decide whether what
you are sorting as a live cell
or a dying cell is actually uh
good or not for your future experiment
and whether that is something that is
going to really affect
the biology that you want to understand
this is an example of that so this is in
this case what the guys did is they
isolated live
dead and dying cells what they see here
is that
essentially there is a segregation along
the pc one but there is some
sort of between live dying and dead cell
there is some
sort of overlapping in some of these
for some of these sort of
clusters and then what they see is that
also the amount of mitochondria
uh reads that they observe or different
percentage of
transcript on that it's the mitochondria
there is a trend
also uh following the pc-1 which is
sort of justified the reason why a high
major underrate is related to
to cell death but then what they also
observed
is that when they do regular glassine of
all of these cells and they're just
trying they actually found three
different clusters one that is
considered
live cells the other that is stress
cells and the other is dying cells
but when they analyze this all of these
clusters have a percentage of
everything else so obviously cluster one
which is this one
we have mostly live cells but there are
also cells that are actually
uh according to the markers here they
are dyn cells okay
and the same happened with the one that
are dead
some of the ones that were labeled as
dead here
actually some of them are
transcriptionally healthy so they are
you know found by the regular haircare
clustering
as live cells so there is not a perfect
correlation
but what is important to know is that
there is not a perfect
uh market to tell you okay this cells is
dying and this cells is actually healthy
so the reason overlapping in here is not
a
sort of clear cut but what is important
to i think they take a message here
is that the use of the microcontrollers
as
a surrogate market of cell death is
actually pretty good
and yes and with this i will i will
finish my presentation
i don't want to get it too long and i
will be happy to take
any questions thank you very much
thank you luciano for that truly
outstanding presentation
unfortunately we're out of time for
today
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months
please remember to share with colleagues
who might be interested in today's topic
and don't miss out on other
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again luciana and thank you to
the audience for
participation until next time